يقول البنتاغون إن هناك
بالون تجسس صيني ثانٍ مشتبه به يتجه
عبر أمريكا اللاتينية رافائيل رومو من سي
إن إن يتابع هذا التطور بالنسبة لنا ،
فماذا نعرف عن هذا
البالون الآخر هو أنك تعرف نسخة طبق الأصل بالضبط
هل هم على استعداد لمشاركتها
أنها تبدو جيدة جدًا  فيرديكا مشابه ونحن
نتعلم عن مشاهدة هذا
البالون الثاني الذي يمكن أن يكون منطادًا ثانيًا يشبه إلى حد
كبير
منطاد المراقبة الصيني الذي يحلق فوق
الولايات المتحدة في
دولتين على الأقل في أمريكا اللاتينية ، أبلغت وسائل الإعلام الكولومبية عن
رؤية منطاد يطير
في  حوالي 70000 قدم فوق
المجال الجوي لدول أمريكا الجنوبية ، نقلاً عن
الجيش الكولومبي ، رأينا أيضًا
تقارير عن منطاد تم رصده فوق
كوستاريكا يوم الجمعة ،
وأكد البنتاغون رؤية منطاد فوق
أمريكا اللاتينية وقال إنه
بالون مراقبة صيني آخر تمتلكه سي إن إن
حصلنا على لقطة فيديو يوم الخميس تظهر
منطادًا تم تحديد موقعه الجغرافي لسان خوسيه ، هذه هي
عاصمة كوستاريكا ، لكن لا يمكننا
التأكيد بشكل مستقل على أنه
بالون صيني بالفعل فحصناه ، لكن لم
تصدر الحكومة الكولومبية ولا كوستاريكا أي تأكيد أو
بيان رسمي حتى الآن بشأن أي منها
ومع ذلك ، فقد انتشر الموضوع كما يمكنك أن تتخيل على نطاق واسع
على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي في المنطقة ، حيث
كان هناك عدد من المشاهدات
لشيء من شهود عيان في
كوستاريكا وكولومبيا
لا يمكن تأكيده في هذه المرحلة من قبل CNN على أنه
منطاد صيني وراء هذا البالون الثاني
واستنادًا إلى التقارير التي قدمتها عن منطقة
فريديريكا لسنوات عديدة ، يمكنني أن أخبرك
أن وجود الصين في
أمريكا اللاتينية ليس شيئًا جديدًا لبكين
منذ سنوات علاقات حميمة جدًا مع
الأنظمة الاستبدادية مثل تلك الموجودة في
فنزويلا ونيكاراغوا وكما قد
تتذكر في  2020 قدمت الصين
قرضًا بقيمة مليار دولار لأمريكا اللاتينية ومنطقة
البحر الكاريبي للحصول على لقاح covid-19